okay so uh trevor lawrence announcing
last night after the team announced it
after reports emerged that he's tested
positive for covet 19.
the team says he has mild symptoms
lawrence says he has relatively mild
symptoms i don't know the difference
between the two the bottom line is he's
got symptoms he's out for a minimum of
10 days according to acc rules which
track current cdc guidelines now this is
where it gets
a little vague
a little fuzzy
and the potential is there for it to get
creative from clemson's standpoint as it
relates to a counting of days standpoint
peter because
reportedly and this comes from pat 40 of
si.com the sample that tested positive
was collected wednesday morning
so 10 days from that is saturday morning
the morning of the game against notre
dame next weekend obviously he won't
play this week against boston college
they don't need him against boston
college they need him against notre dame
i saw a tweet from adam schefter last
night that the symptoms may have started
before
he gave the sample and by cdc guidelines
the 10-day clock starts to run from when
you started to have symptoms so
fuzzy math creative accounting whatever
the case may be hey when did you first
have symptoms and once you understand
how the counting works well i had the
symptoms you know at first i really
wasn't feeling like myself let's say two
weeks ago i i just
the whole thing
invites skepticism and scrutiny because
the ncaa by all appearances has gone
awol on this the conferences aren't
going to do anything that are going to
hurt the broader interests of the
schools the schools are going to do what
they want to do and the kids ultimately
want to play so it's easy to justify
doing whatever it takes to get him back
on the field as long as he doesn't have
a fever or some other obvious symptom
i'd be stunned if he's not on the field
next saturday
mike in my column on monday i
highlighted a story from the new york
times about nick saban's
positive covid test and what exactly
happened after he tested positive
and
as you recall nick saban had to test
negative three times three consecutive
days before he was allowed to coach on
the sidelines uh
in that saturday night's game you know
when they were gonna play georgia okay
so it was gonna be really close he was
gonna have to test
on saturday morning and so what did
alabama do
alabama
took
the test tube with his swab and with his
nasal mucus
whatever that's called okay his
effluents
and they took the test
they put the tests too funny about it on
a private jet
and the private jet
flew to mobile alabama where the test
was examined and when it where it was
determined
that uh you know after however long it i
don't know whether this was this was a
point of care or whether it was the poc
the longer more conclusive test
whichever one it was
test comes back early afternoon
you're in the clear nick you know you've
had three consecutive days of negative
testing so you can coach so mike listen
all i can say is i started to do the
math on trevor lawrence when i heard
this last night and then i heard about
the 10-day thing okay so i i don't i
don't know anything about when you first
feel symptoms or anything like that but
it's
definitely possible
for him if he tests negative on saturday
morning on the 10th day
it's very possible
for him just to get in how many private
jets do you think the clemson football
program has at its instant disposal
probably quite a few of them be what an
hour and a half from clemson to south
bend and private plane you know he can
have a nice little breakfast nice little
team meal on the way walks out here
comes superman to
quarterback against the fighting irish
yeah i mean that's the thing and i hate
to be so cynical about it but we've seen
this time and again especially when it
comes to college football they're going
to get these guys on the field there
isn't that broader sense of order
and
limitations and regulations that the nfl
has in place for its franchises the nfl
isn't going to hesitate to say to
various guys you're not available all
week to practice or for the game and if
it creates a competitive disadvantage so
be it our primary commitment is to keep
this virus out of our facilities and
away from people that it could harm
college football has
found a way to justify
playing this game of
multiple negative tests or
right up against the deadline whatever
the deadline may be all under the guise
of this argument that
and this is when the the tides started
to turn in favor of college football
happening this idea that the players are
somehow safer
if they are having football practice in
games and they're in that structure
because otherwise they'd be out in the
community with the rest of us who are at
risk every day well
trevor lawrence still got it
plenty of guys are still getting it now
maybe there's an alternate universe
where there was no college football this
year and the guys who are playing and
coaching are getting it at a greater
rate
but
at that argument when the most prominent
guy in college football one of the best
draft draft prospects since andrew luck
gets it it it kind of undercuts the
argument
that
playing college football makes these
guys somehow safer they're at risk
wherever they are whether they're
playing college football or not but it
worked it got college football back even
though college football clearly is
having a harder time peter than the nfl
keeping it all together
i think they're having a harder time
because there's two reasons number one
their kids are 20 years old why does
however many people at the university of
wisconsin including evidently what if
the top two or three quarterbacks on the
team all test positive it's because you
know they don't have the same
pounded into your head every single day
that the nfl has and the nfl even slips
up
uh you know even though they're they're
they've been i think by almost all
stretches ridiculously
good at
not having guys test positive but i
think the biggest thing right now when
it comes to trevor lawrence and all of
these college players
is that
unless
they are told
at the end of the day
that you go back to your apartment i
read last night that trevor lawrence
lives alone you go back to your
apartment have no contact with anybody
i'm just not sure it's realistic when
you're talking to kids who are in
college mike if they don't have a
literal bubble to go home to that you're
going to have a very pure season i think
you're going to have these little
conflagrations these little brush fires
for as long as they try to play college
football
and there's a very simple reason for why
that is peter it it it boils down to the
way that people that age are wired
and even though it was a long time ago
for both of us i can still vividly
recall how i felt when i was that age
and there's an inherent selfishness to
being 19 20 21 you want to do the things
that you want to do and when there are
so many damn mixed messages out there
about what's appropriate and what's not
appropriate in our society the people
who want to do the selfish thing
don't need to go very far
to find vindication and justification to
do the selfish thing whether it's it's
all a hoax it's all going to go away the
day after the election masks don't work
whatever you want
to justify
doing what you want to do
19 20 and 21 year olds are susceptible
to that it's no different than the
little kid who asks mom if he can do
something and mom says no so he goes and
he asks dad and if dad says yes good to
go
and with something like this
you've got one parent saying no and the
other parent's saying yes so the kids
just listen to the one who's saying yes
period that's why it's such a problem
among kids that age because there's
enough out there where they can say it's
okay to do this it's okay to do the
things i want to do and that's why
college football is and they're not
getting paid either their paychecks
aren't at risk like they are in the nfl
that's one of the reasons the nfl is
holding together the players understand
at least i hope they do that if games
get cancelled or suspended they're not
getting paid for college players it
doesn't matter
yeah at the end of the day this is it's
unfortunate for trevor lawrence and
look in the
in the very unlikely event that he would
become seriously ill uh with this but
you don't know because there are
stories of uh you know 18 20 22 year old
people who get the coronavirus who
become extremely ill and or die
but but
again
you know trevor lawrence uh this this
probably you know on his way to the nfl
will be a blip on the radar screen it's
a huge story today but it's not going to
have anything to do with what happens to
either his draft status or
probably not going to have anything to
do with how far clemson goes this year
unless obviously he has more serious
symptoms and this lingers for a long
time
what it does is a practical matter it
pushes down the stack the other big
story from this week regarding trevor
lawrence he made those equivocal
comments about going pro or coming back
to clemson and it sparked this
discussion of whether or not he would
just look at the standings look at the
draft order and say
see you next year nfl i ain't playing
for the jets well dabo swinney the coach
of clemson from earlier in the day
before any of this news got out he
addressed the possibility of
trevor lawrence either coming back for
another year or going pro here's coach
swinney
i'm gonna save scholarship for him just
in case uh but you know
i'm not real worried about it
uh you know
he ain't worried about it either he's
he's got one thing on his mind and
that's that's leading the tigers and
having a great season uh this year and
we'll certainly let him stay if that's
what he wants to do but i'd be surprised
if he's if he's back with the tigers
next year but who knows you never know
you never know you never know and look
peter you and i have he's got one thing
on his mind by the way
yeah right well that's that's true um
but uh one thing again those
those those comments were before he
found and you know what though as of
yesterday afternoon if the timeline has
any credence that they're trying to
engineer to let him come back once when
he said that yesterday swinney knew that
lawrence was coveted positive so he at
least has two things on his mind but
peter you and i haven't discussed this
look i i think that if he has any
misgivings about throwing himself into
the draft pool for 2021
i i i think before you go back and play
another year at clemson what you do is
you just sit out the whole year all
together and re-enter the draft pool in
2022 because you're still not going to
get paid your draft stock isn't going to
get any higher and you get to roll the
dice again but the problem is barring a
trade
the team
at the top of the draft order is there
for one very important reason
it sucks
so
you're always going to be faced with
that joe burrow was faced with that and
you and i both know joe burrow at least
contemplated the possibility of trying
to work the system and get the but it's
too hard to do you make too many people
upset at some point you just have to
submit you're going to get 40 million
fully guaranteed and you submit and you
just hope that coaching staff front
office teammates there's enough there to
allow you to flourish and so far in
cincinnati i don't know the answer to
that question because it looks like
borough is the only good thing they have
going other than joe mixon but i think
peter at some point trevor lawrence just
has to accept i'm never going to escape
this unless i sit out two full years
mike the you know the bad thing for
trevor lawrence is that he's so good
and
very very rarely does somebody at the
top of the draft at the very top of the
draft enter a situation where it's
possible to turn it around pretty
quickly
uh you know obviously andrew luck did in
indianapolis because they were down for
a couple of years but had some good
talent and and and again i'm just
reminded
when you look at all this of how
fortunate
patrick mahomes was
that the kansas city chiefs and andy
reid and brett veach fell in love with
him
and used a lot of draft capital to move
up i think from what 27 to 10
uh with buffalo to get that pick because
that just simply does not happen very
often and just as lamar jackson was
fortunate to be the 32nd pick or
whatever he was
just as he was fortunate to be picked
that low
that's it's the opposite end of the
spectrum you want to be the greatest guy
i hear guys every year saying oh my god
it was my dream to be the first pick in
the draft
why
it's other than the exultation and the
and the history and on your wikipedia
page it'll say you were the first pick
of the draft big deal
you know just really big deal and you're
much better off
to either have your star tarnished a
little bit coming out of college
football so that you can go to a little
bit of a lesser team or
to have a really good coach and a good
organization fall in love with you and
trade up unfortunately i don't think
anybody's going to be able to do that
with trevor lawrence but it's like you
look at it mike okay what would you
rather do would you rather be on the new
york jets in 2021 or go back and be with
pika team the jacksonville jaguars in
2022.
it does it really matter do you have a
lot more faith in jacksonville to be a
playoff team in 2024 than you do the new
york jets i mean and and you might i
don't know maybe nick saban becomes the
coach of the jaguars i don't know but
the fact is
you know these guys who are truly great
transcendent college players
are basically slapped in the face when
they come to the nfl
because they're going to go to a bad
team and they're going to get the crap
beat out of them for a while and maybe
for their whole career archie manning
did joe burrow is right now
there's a factor that we're overlooking
and i'm disappointed i hadn't thought of
this sooner because we're very aware of
it when it comes to player contracts
veteran player contracts if the salary
cap is only 175 million next year that
will affect the formulas that determine
how much rookies make so you know i
mentioned 40 million dollars fully
guaranteed over four years well that's
the track it was on because borough got
around 36 million and it goes up every
year because the cap goes up peter that
cap goes down
that four year fully guaranteed contract
if you start with 2021 with a salary cap
of 175 that's not going to be the same
dollars as maybe if you wait until 2022
when the pandemic is cleared assuming
that it does clear assuming that full
stadiums are permissible next year for
the nfl at this point who the hell knows
but that's a factor
for lawrence that wasn't there for any
of the others because the bottom line is
you're going to get what you're going to
get from whoever it is your financial
package is going to be the same as the
top pick
this is going to be the first time that
financial package shrinks so again it's
just a factor because maybe if you do
sit out a year you get more next year
and maybe next year you feel better
about where you're going to go but like
you said it's always going to be the
worst team unless somebody trades up
it's going to be the worst team and when
you're such a great prospect what's
going to happen is
what happened with the bengals and joe
burrow they're going to ignore all
offers they're not going to care
whatever the dolphins wanted to give
them they weren't listening they're
taking the guy and whoever has that
first pick whoever earns that first pick
whether it's next year the year after
they're going to take trevor lawrence
mike i think the one factor that you're
glossing over in this particular case is
that the vast majority of people who
i've spoken to in the nfl
think that this cratering of the cap for
2021
is not a one-year phenomenon it's going
to be not a lot higher in 2022
most likely so
if for if anybody who's advising trevor
lawrence says geez it's only going to be
32 million over four years or whatever
pick a number i don't know uh next year
it really could be a lot higher well
next year it might be a million dollars
higher it's not it's not worth
affecting your decision
uh if you decide to go back decide to go
back either because you don't want to
play for the jets or whoever has the
number one pick or not but i don't think
the finances are going to be a whole lot
different in 22 than 21. j unless unless
unless
the tv contracts get signed
and there's an absolute total pot of
gold that pushes it from 175 to 230 in
the first in the first year of the new
tv deals but
i think that's problematic too
that's a whole other subject but i think
that's problematic as well well well
peter i think we can agree we don't know
where it's going in 2022 we know where
it's going in 2021 and that's down the
crapper yeah 2022 it's going to go up
the question is how far does it go up
but it's going to be better in 2022
again it's just a factor to consider
that no number one overall pick has had
to consider in the past and i mentioned
earlier let's be clear on this
you can avoid the draft altogether if
you sit out two full years nobody's ever
gonna sit out two full years no college
football no pro football for two years
and even then you would you would be an
undrafted rookie free agent and there
would be limitations on what they could
pay you for the first few years and you
would never get that pot of gold however
big or small it may be until you get
yourself in line for your second
contract so you know as much as i love
to see a john elway or an eli manning's
story where a guy stands up and makes a
power play
it's hard to do by way of sitting out
now peter and we need to take a break
after this but
we can't rule out the possibility of
trevor lawrence just simply making it
known i don't want to play for the jets
i don't want to play for the jaguars i'm
not i just don't want to do it and i'm
making it known i don't want to do it
now again it's not the easiest thing in
the world to pull off but
though on the rare occasions when guys
try to do it it's worked
it has and let's just say for the sake
of argument and how ironic would this be
let's just say for the sake of argument
that trevor lawrence says i'm not
playing for the jets i'm coming out but
if they draft me i'm not showing up
and how ironic would it be
if the denver broncos call the jets and
offer them four ones
for that first pick in the draft and
john elway becomes the mentor
to
to one of the great college quarterbacks
to come out since
john elway
well you know they're already saying
that arch manning is going to pick his
spot with uh
with archie leading the way as he did
for eli making it known where arch
doesn't want to play in six or seven
years when he makes it to the nfl so you
know players have a lot more leverage
than when they realize especially the
guys at the very top and maybe lawrence
is going to figure that out maybe that's
the best play not
go back to clemson not sit out a year
just use your leverage and don't be
afraid of the criticism you may get
because there's going to be people who
support you i know i will because i
think more and more guys should
recognize that they shouldn't just
blindly walk into this process because
you can end up with a bad coach
bad owner bad front office bad teammates
and your career gets derailed and you
never even had really much of a chance
and we see how it is in today's nfl if
you don't pick it up quickly
you're gone
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports